foreign
Cincinnati Ohio Andrew welcome to the
show
oh hello hey hey
how you doing this is awesome can you
hear me okay yeah Andrew you're live on
the Ramsay show how can we help oh
anyway so this is a kind of a student
loan question there's layers of this so
if I you if you ask me questions if you
feel like I need to clarifying right so
um in the end I own a oh about thirty
nine thousand dollars
in student loans
um so 12 000 of that is to my parents
and then there's about three or like
four or five of them that are just
federal student loans
um my my father decided it was like a
Parent PLUS Loan and he decided that he
wanted to pay off the loan
um about two or three years ago
and now he
um I'm in a situation with work when I'm
earning a lot more money than I used to
and I'm gonna be able to pay off these
loans a lot faster and then went on top
of Biden doing the ten thousand dollars
you know and if Biden's gonna go ahead
and oop me I'll take it to the basket
you know what I'm saying so I am um
that was a sports reference yeah we just
went to Sports Center there I want to
address that in a minute but keep going
what's your question
so the question is is so my dad went
went ahead and paid off that student one
and now that I'm in a situation of work
when I'm making a lot more money
um he he was telling me that he he wants
that money back right rightfully so and
so I'm stuck in between this should I go
ahead and do the um the baby steps for
the student loans or should I go ahead
and pay off my dad first which is the
biggest one and get rid of that slave
master relationship
um
that's interesting so you're saying hey
should I do the debt snowball as is even
though the 12 000 is at the very end of
it but Dad's hanging over my neck going
hey I want this money back how much does
he need this money versus it just being
a moral hey I paid this off but it was
for you I'd like the money back
is he in a tough Financial spot
no he's he's not and honestly he's he's
told me that it could be like two three
four years like it's fine
um so he's like this is not like every
time he's on the phone he's like Hey
where's my loan money at no no no no no
nothing like that but then this goes
back to the work part of things is that
I'm in this situation where I'm able to
pay off a lot more money within the next
like 18 weeks but the money's not going
to last forever so it's either pay off
the Federal loans and just like
they just do the debt snowball just
smallest to largest and you'll get there
a lot faster and then when you get to
the end time to pay dad back and you're
done with this whole thing within what a
year
well so no so I guess it is where things
get a little confusing is that I so I'm
a respiratory therapist shout out
respiratory therapist
um and because of um covid and all that
stuff they're really desperate for
nurses and respiratory therapists and
doctors in all Healthcare World
um and so they're paying me an extra
about 60 an hour would just be about
ninety dollars an hour
um which makes a lot of disposable
income after this
um but after all this is done and
they're like all right gravy trains over
get off you know like I only have about
three four hundred dollars left of to go
towards debt and that's what I'm saying
that's fourteen thousand dollars is it's
going to be there for a long time
so how long will it take to pay off your
debt making this extra money you're
making right now thirty nine thousand
how quickly can you pay that off
making this
if you're in Texas so
let's see
so I'll be honest I haven't really
looked at yeah yeah can I can I jump in
Hey listen bro let me let me help you
out there's nothing confusing about what
you threw at us nothing I kept waiting
for the confusing part the only thing
that's confusing
it's not layers you'd use the debt
snowball make an extra income right
there's a season in your in your work
life where you you got a boon of income
I mean it's it's it's it's kind of
booming for a while yes you attack it
faster right but it's not like as a
respiratory therapist you're not going
to have an opportunity to make more
money elsewhere
um and and and you're acting like you
know the income's gonna go away and
you'll never be able to get a raise or
move up I mean you're thinking too hard
you stop you just work the snowball work
the debt snowball smallest to largest
intense second job third job whatever
you got to do gazelle intense whatever
that looks like for you to pay every
loan back including your debt and
honestly you'll get there I think a lot
quicker than you realize this is not an
in intermountable amount of debt and you
can do this it's not going to be there
forever and and you just have to stop
thinking so much and get busy how much
money do you have in the bank right now
Andrew
um we're going on about about seven
thousand okay we're taking six of that
just throw it this debt we're gonna take
this amazing income you have to clean up
the rest we're paying dad back and all
of a sudden 12 months from now no
excuses you're completely debt free with
a fully funded emergency fund it's that
simple no layers George this was not
that this was not a tiramisukan it's not
that complicated not that many layers
for you man just don't overthink it you
got this one thing at a time Focus
intensity and you'll be debt free in no
time this is the Ramsey Show